c'est de la sculpture c'est de
l'installation après on l'appelle du
street art de l'art contemporain j'en
sais rien moi tant que je me régale et
que je kiffe ce que je fais que je suis
droit dans mes bottes ça me va très bien
voilà c'est bon on est bon un autre
vas-y
non je vais pas l'allumer là non
regardez là
en fait je fais deux yeux un oeil un
autre œil et là tu as les dents
tu vois
et voilà
c'est quoi le but bah c'est de cette
délirer quoi tu vois c'est de changer un
peu le regard du truc voilà quoi tu vois
tu t'attendais à si on veut à ce que je
prenne un briquet
tu as un truc drôle quoi tu vois tu as
la télé tu as la télé péter avec les
pavés qu'on servit à la casser enfin ça
raconte un truc après moi je fais pas de
politique ou quoi je fais juste un truc
du coup ça vous fait marrer ou pas
c'est drôle ou quoi voilà ça fait c'est
anecdotique voilà il pensait que je
mettais le feu